قائد فاغنر اعلن السيطرة الكاملة
على باخموت رفع العلم الروسي.
زينيسكي يستنجد بالعرب رغم كثافة
الدعم الغربي. فما هو الرد
العربي بينما استحوذت قمة العرب
على المشهد العالمي وواشنطن
تراقب عن كثب. واوروبا اخيرا
عقوباتنا ارتدت علينا. خطأ يكشف
مخبأ بوتين السري وخطة روسية
ماكرة لاستنزاف الذخائر ومنظومات
الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانية. الرئيس
الصيني يحضر قوة عظمى قادمة
لمواجهة مجموعة السبع. والاتحاد
الاوروبي يتملق لاصحاب العيون
الضيقة. ورئيس مجلس السيادة
السوداني يقيل حميتي ويعين بديلا
له. القمم تشتعل. تزامنا مع
الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية حرب
التحالفات نشأت بين العالم
المتنافسة هنا فيه روشيم
اليابانية حيث القى الامريكان
قنبلتهم النووية ها هي قدما
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن تطأ
المكان الذي حصلت فيه الكارثة
بايدي اسلافه. فيذهب يمنة ويسرة
لياخذ صورا تذكارية لكنه لم يقدم
ولو بسيطا عن الكارثة هيروشيما
التي استقبلت القنبلة النووية
اليوم تحتضن قاتليها. لتجتمع
مجموعة السبع فقط لمناقشة وبحث
العلاقات الصينية الروسية
والتوسع العسكري والاقتصادي
لبكين. الرد جاء من الصين هذه
المرة. حيث يجمع الرئيس الصيني
شي جين بينغ ما يسمى بالقوة
العظمى القادمة. نعم انهم قادة
اسيا الوسطى في مواجهة قمة في
اجتماع هو الاول من نوعه منذ
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي. وهناك
قال شي ان بلاده مستعدة لمساعدة
دول اسيا الوسطى لتعزيز امنها
وقدراتها الدفاعية وفق تعبيره.
وبالعودة لقمة مجموعة السبع قالت
رئيسة المفوضية الاوروبية انه
يجب رفض اي مبادرات سلام تنص على
مفاوضات متساوية بين روسيا
واوكرانيا. لكن الذي سيقبل بسلام
غير متساوي هذه هو اي كلام خلاص؟
هل تريدين اطفاء حرب اوكرانيا ام
ان في استمرارها فائدة لك
ليعلنها ديمتري ميدفيديف نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي انه يمكن
لروسيا ان تتفاوض بشأن اوكرانيا
فقط مع واشنطن وهناك سيتم فقط
الحديث حول شروط وبنية النظام
العالمي بعد الحرب. ومن حرب
القمم ننتقل معارك المساعدات.
حيث نقلت شبكة سي ان ان عن مصادر
مطلعة ان ادارة بيض اشارت الى
الحلفاء الاوروبيين في الاسابيع
الاخيرة بان الولايات المتحدة
ستسمح لهم بتصدير مقاتلات من
طراز اف ستة عشر الى اوكرانيا
اذا كان هذا هو ما قرر الحلفاء
القيام به. واشنطن تتجه للدوس
على خطوط موسكو الحمراء بانتظار
الرد الروسي يا سادة. لكن قبل
ذلك هل تجرأ على خطوة كهذه لا
يبدو ذلك ممكنا في الوقت الحالي.
فتركيز واشنطن ينصب الان على
تسريع ايصال الاسلحة التي تعهدت
بتقديمها الى كييف وفقا لمسؤول
في ادارة الرئيس جو بايدن بينما
قالت التقارير ان بايدن ابلغ
قادة مجموعة السبعة دعمه لمبادرة
مشتركة تهدف لتدريب الطيارين
الاوكران على مقاتلات اف ستة
عشر. فهل هو تدريب لذر الرماد
على ام ان الطائرات ستأتي بعد
تدريب الاوكراني عليها؟ حيرتمونا
يا ابناء العم سام. ان كانت
مواجهة مباشرة مع الدب الروسي
فابلغونا على الاقل كي نحضر
انفسنا في هذه الحرب العالمية
لننتقل الى حرب العقوبات. هنا
اعتبر وزير الخارجية والعلاقات
الاقتصادية الهنجري بيتر سيارتو
ان العقوبات الغربية ضد روسيا
تجعل اوروبا تدفع اعلى مما تدفعه
موسكو نفسها. اي انه يقول
عقوباتنا ارتدت علينا. فكفانا
اسرافا بالعقوبات. لكن الولايات
المتحدة تتجاهل ضرر العقوبات.
وها هي تحضر خلال قمة السبع لفرض
عقوبات ستمنع نحو سبعين كيانا من
روسيا ودول اخرى من الحصول على
الصادرات الامريكية عبر ادراجها
في اللائحة التجارية السوداء.
اضافة لنحو ثلاثمائة عقوبة ضد
افراد وكيانات بهدف تقييد وصول
روسيا الى المنتجات الضرورية
لتعزيز قدراتها القتالية في
ساحات المعارك بحسب وكالة
الصحافة الفرنسية. وبالعودة الى
الحرب الاوكرانية. اعلنت الرئاسة
الاوكرانية ان الرئيس
فلودمرزنيسكي اصدر مرسوما بتشكيل
مجلس لتحرير شبه جزيرة القرن.
بينما اكدت جورنال ان الضربات
الصاروخية الروسية لاوكرانيا
تهدف بالدرجة لاستنزاف الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني والذخائر
ومنظومات الدفاع الجوي التي
تتسلمها كييب. وفي باخموت حيث
مفرمة اللحم التي لا تتوقف.
اعترفت نائبة وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني انا مليار بتقدم
القوات المسلحة الروسية في مدينة
باخموت ذلك فيما كشف رئيس مجموعة
عن ان السيطرة على المدينة لن
تكون خلال الايام القادمة. ومن
اوكرانيا الى روسيا حيث وقع
الروس في خطأ فادح وذلك بنشر
المخططات الخاصة بمخبأ الرئيس
بوتين المجهز لاحتمال حدوث حرب
نووية مؤخرا وفقا لموقع فهل هناك
خطأ روسي حقا ام انه مجرد ايهام
روسي للغرب? اجتماع عربي وترقب
عالمي. القمم في كل مكان لكن قمة
واحدة هي من استحوذت على المشهد
العالمي. نعم انها القمة العربية
في مدينة جدة السعودية. التي
جعلت العالم يصوب انظاره نحوها.
خصوصا بعد تجاهل العرب للوصاية
الامريكية على المنطقة هذه
المرة. واشنطن لم تملك الا ان
تراقب المشهد العربي عن كثب.
وهنا وللمرة الاولى تستضيف قمة
عربية الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي الذي
استنجد لدعم خطة العشر للسلام
مذكرا المسلمين بالتعايش
الاوكراني مع الاسلام في شبه
جزيرة القرم فعن اي سلام يتحدث
وهو الذي قالها صريحة بانه يدعم
انتهاكات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
فلسطين ليقول ولي العهد السعودي
محمد بن سلمان رئيس القمة
العربية ان السعودية مستعدة لبذل
جهود الوساطة لحل الازمة بين
روسيا واوكرانيا. هناك في جدة
حضر القادة لينقلوا صورة قوية
بان هذه القمة تستطيع ان تخلق
واقعا عربيا جديدا يكون له ثقل
في العالم فبعد عزلة عن العالم
ها هو الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
يعود للقمة العربية بعد انقطاع
دام لاثني عشر عاما. وفي ختام
القمة جددت الجامعة العربية
التأكيد على مركزية القضية
الفلسطينية باعتبارها احد
العوامل الرئيسة للاستقرار في
المنطقة. كما دان الجامعة
العربية في اعلان جدة باشد
العبارات الممارسات والانتهاكات
التي تستهدف الفلسطينيين في
ارواحهم وممتلكاتهم ووجودهم
كافة. القمة لم تنسى قضايا
اعضائها الاخرين الذين يعانون من
ازمات حقيقية وهي الملف السوري
واليمني والليبي واللبناني.
ليختتم اعلان جدة بالتأكيد على
ضرورة وقف التدخلات الخارجية في
الشؤون الداخلية العربية. فهل
حان للعرب ان يعلنوا عن انفسهم
كقوة يحسب لها الشرق والغرب الف
حساب? الاحداث والتطورات. صرح
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
بان تركيا ليست مستعدة لانضمام
السويد الى الناتو الان. حمل
شارل ميشيل رئيس المجلس الاوروبي
الصين مسئولية ممارسة ضغوط على
موسكو كي توقف حربها في
اوكرانيا. واضاف ان مصلحة
الاوروبي بالحفاظ على تعاون بناء
ومستقر مع الصين. اعفى رئيس مجلس
السيادة الانتقالي في السودان
عبدالفتاح البرهان قائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دجلو
حميتي من منصب النائب الاول
لرئيس مجلس السيادة وكلف ما لك
عقار بدلا منه. قمة العرب اوفت
بوعودها. برأيكم هل تعتبر قمة
جدة اعلان عودة العرب كقطب عالمي
لا يستهان